it appears as though everyone is  finished  deputy velashan please tally the votes  electors please hold up only your ballot  for the office  of the president of the united states  thank you electors please hold up only  your ballot  for the office of vice president of the  united states  thank you  madam secretary we have six votes for  joseph r biden for president  and six votes for kamala d harris for  vice president  thank you electors please  sign seven copies of the original  certificates of vote  the certificate of vote is the official  record  of your vote here today and will be  provided to the president of the united  states senate  and the u.s archives this chief  justice of the federal district court  nevada and my  office